marie bonjour diamant
marie
[Musique]
tous vous vous tenez sur le seuil avez
vous peur de ne pas trouver le royaume
quel royaume celui des rhodes
vous savez comme moi qu'il n'y a qu'un
seul vrai royaume c'est celui de dieu
et le royaume de dieu est déjà là nous
devons nous préparer pour cela vous
devez l'avait là sourires de votre
corruption et venir au monde à nous
tels des enfants étaient cachés trop
longtemps mais maintenant c'est vous qui
vous cacher
chacun de vous
derrière l'apparence de votre foi
pourrait citer vos psaume présenter ou
sacrifice comme si votre coeur et votre
esprit
ce que vous devez à dieu était quoi et
cela accompli pour reporter le coeur
léger et retourner à la vie qui vous
convient une vie confortable une vie
dont les jours passent tranquillement et
sans souffrance pour vous comme le
rêveur mais tu dois tu réveiller maclin
couvrez vieux et voix
le petit garçon de pierre s'essayer au
pied du rhabiller et le chantait c'était
si beau de l'entendre
pierre ne s'est jamais remis de l'avoir
laissée pour partir tu as des enfants
oui une fille esther et maintenant on
est elle se taire
il ya eu la sécheresse dans les collines
où nous vivions presque plus rien de
pousser mais rld a envoyé ses
collecteurs avec la maison du camp j'ai
refusé ils ont envoyé un officiel et
c'est toute ma récolte qu'ils ont prise
ma femme était enceinte elle a lutté
mais elle n'a pas survécu
je suis désolé
le royaume va arriver mari il va arriver
je peux attendre pour ça je peux trouver
la patience
les morts les morts que nous avons aimé
se lèveront et marchons à nouveau à nos
côtés
ça a été premier mari lorsque le royaume
arrive ma famille sera là
collection m'a été donné par le baptiste
il a fait 108 sainte il cérémonie
qui n'a fait que ça
ouvre des yeux lumière
ça a commencé
[Musique]
je ne faut pas l'arrêter
l ex pas l'arrêter
je serai toujours là je ne partirai pas
pareil
[Musique]
tu témoignes rade mois